We're talking about life
aboard the International Space
Station, featuring my interview
with the guy who was there
for nearly a year, Scott Kelly.
I had to ask Scott
the question that we
all want to know the answer to.
How do bathrooms work in space?
Check it out.
The zero-G toilets,
they work OK for you?
Very complicated toilet,
and it works pretty well.
Why should it be complicated?
You know, you've got to you
separate the air from the urine
before it's sent to a tank.
OK.
So the whole--
SCOTT: The machinery
- --the whole toilet system.
Oh, the system, and
then some of the urine.
And usually when I
talk about the toilet,
I'm also talking about
the water processes.
NEIL: Recovery.
The recovery system that turns
our urine into drinking water.
So it's pretty sophisticated.
Even though intellectually I
know that's an entirely doable
thing.
Yeah.
Just emotionally,
that just sounds nasty.
Yeah.
Yeah, I drank my pee
for a whole year.
Right, right.
Actually, I actually
drank everyone's pee.
Exactly.
SCOTT: All mixed together.
What happens to all
that is not the H2O--
Yeah.
--from the urine.
What happens to that?
It's put into a container and
then eventually, when that tank
fills, we put them
into smaller tanks,
send them down to
the Russian segment.
They put them in the
Progress, their resupply ship,
and eventually that burns
up in the atmosphere.
And then that tank
will eventually
come back with urine in it.
We put it into our system.
We turn it into water,
eventually brine--
So what burns up
in the atmosphere?
The whole Progress.
NEIL: Oh, I didn't know that.
- The whole spaceship.
- OK.
So that spaceship
is designed-- it's
your garbage disposal system.
Exactly.
NEIL: I didn't know that.
And that is a
critical resource.
The ability to get
garbage off of a spaceship
is something that is not simple.
[applause]
Sasheer, what are you doing?
Huh?
It made me thirsty.
Sasheer.
Do you want some?
No, not now.
It's tart.
Oh, that's nasty.
Nasty.